-Well, it seems like there's so
much going on right now.
Last night was the Rockefeller
Center Christmas tree got lit.
The World Cup --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The World Cup is in full swing.
There's a new trailer for the
"Super Mario Bros. Movie."
-Ooh!
-That looks good.
And Subway just announced that
they're going to sell
a foot-long cookie.
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
First up, the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree.
Last night was the big lighting.
Thousands of people
waited around for hours
just for one second
of excitement.
Yeah, it was
just like watching...
the World Cup.
Yeah.
Games are long,
sometimes there's a tie,
and the fans in Qatar
aren't even allowed to drink.
But it hasn't stopped them
from enjoying the matches,
which are full of
running, jumping, and kicking,
kind of like...
"Super Mario."
The new trailer for
the movie just came out.
Yeah, it's a whole movie
about a plumber,
which is exactly who you'll
be calling if you eat a...
foot-long cookie from Subway.
That's right --
a giant 12-inch-long cookie.
They're selling them
for National Cookie Day
or, as stoners call it...
Christmas.
The tree is so beautiful
when it's lit.
But you know
who isn't lit right now?
Fans at the World Cup.
There's no booze.
But they still went wild when
Team USA's best player scored
while getting kneed
in the groin.
Yeah, he took one
right in his...
cookies.
Seriously, if there's --
If you eat this whole thing,
you won't be hitting your
weight-loss...
goooooal!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There are 16 countries left,
but there can only be
one winner.
Right now,
every country is hoping...
"it's a-me."
So, in conclusion...
what a star...
in Qatar...
"Super Mar"...
you took it too far.
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]